I'm an ophthalmologist by background and
I actually started my career in 2001 at
Columbia University Michael F Chang MD
adjunct nlm investigator and director
National Eye Institute as a nlm
postdoctoral fellow and since then I've
spent 20 years in Academia as a
clinician scientist working at the
interface of Ophthalmology and
biomedical informatics
in November 2020 I started a new job at
NIH as director of the national Eye
Institute and I'm really excited to be a
investigator here at the National
Library of Medicine because you know in
a way it's what I started my career
doing
at the national Eye Institute our
mission is to eliminate vision loss and
improve quality of life through vision
research and that's an application
domain and at the National Library of
Medicine what we do is methodological
research in biomedical informatics and
data science and I think it's really
important to connect the methodology
with the application close-up of the
newborn baby's face text retinopathy of
prematurity one of the things that I do
is I develop artificial intelligence
methods to diagnose a pediatric retinal
disease called retinopathy of
prematurity it's one of the leading
causes of blindness in babies around the
world Stevie Wonder Smiles while
performing Stevie Wonder is someone who
went blind from ROP in the 1950s before
there was a treatment for it and we've
developed an AI system that received FDA
breakthrough status graphic illustrating
the progress of retinal vascular disease
and one of the things that we've been
doing is trying to find ways to apply AI
to real world problems in eye care for
kids a premature baby bathed in blue
light has a White Gauze masking their
eyes babies who are premature and
therefore at risk for retinopathy
prematurity come disproportionately from
urban and rural medically underserved
areas and there are huge challenges in
terms of delivering Eye Care and Health
Care overall to those babies Dr Chang
examines a newborn baby and so one of
the things that I did at the very
beginning of my career is that we work
to develop and validate telemedicine
systems for retinopathy of prematurity
diagnosis and now what we're starting to
do is to experiment with can we
Implement AI artificial intelligence
into those Dr Chang points to a retinal
image on the computer screen
telemedicine systems to be able to
improve the accuracy and the quality of
the diagnosis that we're able to make
remotely
there's never been a time in history
where we've had so much access to
Science and Technology as being applied
to health care and I think one of the
challenges for the future is how to move
things like biomedical informatics and
artificial intelligence and data science
into the mainstream of healthcare
the gray and blue and LM logo serving
scientists in society